ピッ！
ゴボゴボゴボ・・・
は）あ～いいですね～
H）ふ～～よ～し
は）やりますよ
H)あ～いいよ
は）こんにちは！はじめしゃちょーと！
Ｈ）ブンブン　ハローユ・・・
は）今回はヒカキンさん家に遊びに来ております！
ドン！！
は）僕は親分に、僕が進化したところを見せてあげたい。
Ｈ）ウッヒッヒッヒッヒッww
は）いやもう、進化しましたよ
Ｈ）いや、進化し続けてる
は）めっちゃ進化しました
Ｈ）それは、知ってるけど
は）何が進化したかというと、
は）僕はですね～
トン！トン！トン！トン！トン！
Ｈ）料理ができる！
は）料理ができるようになったんですよ！
Ｈ）ウッフッフッフッフww
は）親分最近すごい疲れてると思うので・・・
Ｈ）おぉ嬉しいなぁ～
は）今日はですね
Ｈ）卵！
は）簡単レシピ！
Ｈ）へ～
は）もうすごいその、卵を使う
は）タンパク質ＭＡＸみたいな
Ｈ）おお～いいね～
は）力がすごい出る！
は）絶対美味しいと思うんで
Ｈ）ＯＫ
は）親分と一緒に美味しい卵料理を作って行こうと思います
は）では、行こう！
は）ＯＫです。バッチリです。
Ｈ）ｗｗｗｗ
は）よ～し作りますよ
は）本当に作りますよ
Ｈ）卵～
は）塩コショウとかありますか？
Ｈ）わ～あるねたぶん
は）あ、フライパン使うかもしれないです
は）では、早速作って行きましょ～
Ｈ）まずは、手を洗いましょう。親分
Ｈ）洗いましょう
Ｈ）何だい、何だい、何だい？
Ｈ）何かしてんのか～
は）何にもしてないっすよ
Ｈ）なんか誘導してくる感じが
Ｈ）あれタオルがねぇ
Ｈ）ちょっと待って
は）じゃ、まずはですねぇ
は）卵
は）まずは、卵を準備します
Ｈ）はい
は）はい
は）こちらの、うみたて卵
Ｈ）ふ～ん
は）普通に美味しいので・・・
は）もういきなり、フライパンに入れちゃいます
は）じゃあここで僕のテクニックを見せますよ
は）4つ一気に割ります！
Ｈ）マジで！
は）行きますよ！
Ｈ）うん
は）あ～～～～
Ｈ）ああ～～～～
コン！カン！ココン！
Ｈ）フフフフウフフフフフwww
Ｈ）フフフフフww
Ｈ）www
Ｈ）おいw絶対マジでマジでやったかと思ったww
は）ハハハハハww
ばかやろう
Ｈ）怖かったの
Ｈ）この辺がもう
Ｈ）なんかこの辺に仕掛けてあんのかなと思ってｗｗ
は）でも、いつもよりかは分かりずらっかたですよね？
Ｈ）けど、全然分かりずらっかたww
は）よしwよしwよしw
は）というわけで、今回のドッキリは
Ｈ）www
は）Ｈikakin家で卵を投げたらどうなるか、ドッキリでした
Ｈ）ちょっとおもしろいｗｗｗ
は）ｗｗｗ
Ｈ）笑っちゃうんだよちょっとｗｗｗ